I remember one time I'm talking to this  Jewish guy who had dealerships was 35  years old show me six million dollars of  cash and I've never seen that kind of  money before 21. I said how the hell do  you have six million dollars of cash  that's crazy he says let me tell you one  thing about Jews on why most Jews have  money when one Jew makes money five Jews  make money we make money together he  said capitalism if you really want to  make a lot of money as long as everybody  around you makes money and you make  money you're gonna be fine if you're the  only person that makes money and people  around you don't make money you're not  going to be fine